here we are in one of the reddest cities
and one of the reddest counties in one
of the reddest states but we put the
silly national politics aside to do
what's best for the people we were
elected to serve and the best thing to
do was to sign contracts for wind and
solar currently we're 90 percent
renewable energy and the spring will be
the largest city in the country there
will be a hundred percent renewable
energy and I think we're getting a fresh
approach because the national politics
is Texas wasn't supposed to do this
that's a that's this liberal progressive
idea up in the Northeast they should be
doing that but the decision was first
and foremost an economic decision here
everything that we do in the city is
built on 30-year horizons so in my case
when it came to power that meant taking
a 30 year outlook on what the cost of
the energy is the best part about
renewable energy is that with a solar
panel or even a wind turbine for the
most part it's not difficult to keep
them working and they have no fuel costs
so 30 years from today they will be
making energy that costs nothing to the
market
[Music]
you